MANO MARKS: Hi.
This is Mano Marks.
This is the second episode in a
miniseries designed to show
you how to get started with the
Google Maps STK for iOS.
In this episode, we'll walk
through creating a project and
adding in the SDK.
This episode assumes that you've
downloaded the SDK,
registered for an API key, and
set up your development
environment, and you've
successfully built and run the
Google Maps SDK demo
sample project.
If you haven't done that, you
may want to start with the
first video in the series,
which you can
do by clicking here.
Let's start by creating
a new project.
For simplicity, we'll create a
single view application and
won't use storyboards.
You can, of course, use
storyboards if you wish.
And here's a video that shows
you how to do it.
Once you've created a project,
you need to add the framework
to your project.
Open up Finder and navigate
to the folder where you
downloaded the SDK.
Select the Google Maps Framework
folder and drag it
to the Frameworks group
in your project.
When prompted, select Copy Items
Into the Destination
Groups Folder.
Now, right click or control
click on the framework that
you've just added.
Select Show in Finder.
And in Finder, navigate to the
Resources folder and click and
drag the Google Maps Bundle,
again to the Frameworks group
of your project.
This time, make sure the Copy
Items Into Your Destination
Group Folder is not selected.
Next, you're going to add in
the libraries the framework
will need to run.
To do that, select the project
and then select Targets and
Build Phases.
Open up Link Binary With
Libraries, and click on the
plus sign to add in libraries.
Here's a complete list of
the frameworks that
you'll need to add in.
This list can also be
found at this link.
Next, switch from the target
to the project and select
Build Settings.
Make sure the architecture is
set to ARMv7 or ARMv7s.
In the other linker flag
section, add in -objc.
Finally, let's add in your API
key to the app delegate.
First, import the Google Maps
framework to your app delegate
using import GoogleMaps
GoogleMaps.h.
Add the following to
your application--
didFinishLaunchingWithOptions
method--
replacing API key with
your API key.
In the final video of this
series, you will
create your first map.